twenty-five-year-old zetina is a single
mom with
three children she doesn't have a job
and her life in the village of mahabal
in western madagascar has become
virtually impossible
her children are malnourished but now
there's at least some help
a team from msf doctors without borders
has arrived
[Music]
i am really happy i dance like this as
i'm really happy
without this aid we would have died we'd
been eating plant roots which gave us
permanent stomach aches
as a woman i personally no longer have
enough energy to go and dig up those
roots
even men are unable to do so anymore
families in desperate need for food and
medical assistance are gathering
doctors without borders has set up
makeshift centers
some of the families looking for help
had to walk long distances
we've come upon a food crisis here so we
launched an urgent deployment
we choose to do this this way because
health centers and the region's
infrastructures cannot deal with a
crisis of this magnitude
right now we take charge of children
with cases of severe and moderate
malnutrition
but we also treat other diseases mostly
malaria
intestinal parasitus and diarrhea
madagascar is experiencing the worst
drought in 40 years
aid agencies warn that more than a
million people here
are facing severe food shortages but
it's just one of many countries
with the same difficulties the report
reveals
a dramatic worsening of the food
security situation in 2020
the number of malnourished people in the
world
continues to rise 118 million more
people were facing hunger
than in 2019 moderate or severe food
insecurity
has been climbing slowly for six years
and now affects almost a third of the
world's population
africa is hardest hit followed by latin
america
the report says kovid 19 has had an
effect
but so too have conflicts around the
world and it says
urgent action is needed to avoid an
obvious catastrophe
muhammad al jazeera sasuke de pere
is the head of systems analysis for
nutrition
with the world food programme she joins
us by skype from the hague
thank you for your time what shocked you
most in the
findings of this report
well what shocked us most is the the
increase and
there has been a stagnation of the
reduction since 2014
but now we are seeing an increase of the
number of
hungry worldwide up to 811 million
in 2020. and what does that mean for the
world food program and its work
it means that we're trying to reach even
more people
uh this year we're aiming to reach 138
million people with
uh immediate food assistance um and that
we are continuing
our work working with governments to
improve the situation
for the longer term for many many more
people
up to three billion people who cannot
afford a
healthy nutritious diet one of the
biggest challenges
for the world food program right now is
it
you know access in conflict areas or
is it funding what are the biggest
challenges that you're facing
well we're facing the the drivers of
this situation which is
uh as you said conflict it's the
economic downturn from kovit and it's
climate change
and then amid that yes we want to
provide
support and we need funding for that
which is also constrained
and where kovit has also decreased
budgets
of foreign assistance so it's even
harder
to meet all the needs especially as
they're increasing sure
i want to pick up something you said
about climate change impacting
your work how is climate change making
things harder for the world food program
feeding people who who desperately need
it
well it drives up the the numbers but
it's also the
the sudden sudden impacts we try hard to
to predict um unlike droughts you can
kind of predict floods is uh is more
difficult
um and yeah another disaster type
earthquakes of course even
even more what you just showed from
madagascar
it's really the the drought and the
prolonged drought
that makes it really hard all right
thank you very much for your time i'll
have to leave it there saskia de pere
there
uh from the world food program she